[Musik]
wer schafft bezahlbaren wohnraum wir
sehen auch die angespannten
wohnungsmärkte wir wissen dass damit
soziale schieflagen verbunden sind aber
die anspannung sie rührt auch daher dass
eine hohe nachfrage auf ein geringes
angebot trifft die große aufgabe ist
also doch das mehr und schneller gebaut
wird und wir wollen für bezahlbaren
wohnraum eintreten eine eigene wohnung
ein haus ist für viele eine hoffnung und
das muss auch für die mitte der
gesellschaft wieder möglich sein
eigentum zu erwerben
ich will dass wir wieder mindestens
400.000 neue wohnungen pro jahr schaffen
davon 100.000 sozialen wohnungsbau damit
junge menschen ihre dörfer nicht
verlassen sondern als familien dahin
zurückkehren ebenso im ländlichen raum
die telekommunikation die auf einen
stand ist wie vor 20 jahren wir wollen
bundesweit ihm wegen deckeln und wir
wollen einen mieter durchsetzen liebe
genossinnen und genossen
er wird man die linken wollen so weit
gehen dass es sogar einen mieten stopp
geben soll dann sind auch noch wörter in
der diskussion wie mietpreis bremse
mieten decke was steckte alles hinter
also grundsätzlich zeigt sich an dem
thema erst mal dass das thema mieten
unter den nägeln brennt weil jede partei
findet dazu die einen oder die anderen
wort in ihrem programm wenn wir über
diese ganz konkreten begriffe sprechen
also mietpreis bremse beispielsweise
dann sind wir in einem setting wo im
prinzip der anstieg gebremst werden soll
den preisen der medien die mietpreise
tatsächlich haben das heißt wenn eine
neue familie in eine wohnung einzieht
dann soll halt im prinzip dieser preis
den die meter ansteigt gebremst werden
bei dem mietpreis deckel wiederum gibt
es dann eher eine maximal preise
bepreisung für bestimmte
quadratmeterzahlen im wohnraum und beim
mietpreis stopp geht es dann wirklich
das tatsächlich darum dass einzufrieren
das problem ist es gibt die mietpreis
bremse dass ich schon diese wird aber
natürlich ein stück weit im politischen
diskurs umgang und auch in der
tatsächlichen umsetzung beispielsweise
dadurch dass es sehr kurzfristige mieten
gibt und quasi mieter sehr schnell durch
rotiert werden und damit im endeffekt
der tatsächliche preis boon der wirklich
stattgefunden letzten jahren überhaupt
gar nicht gestoppt wurde im städtischen
bereich haben die linken da die konkrete
vorstellung wie der bezahlbarer wohnraum
geschaffen werden sollen sie haben
zumindest die radikalsten forderungen
weil die tatsächlich auch beinhalten
dass eine ja in eine situation in der
ich als vermieter weise eine wohnung
haben und die vermieter dass ich die
nicht zum eigenbedarf zum beispiel
umwandeln darf was sie wollen das
weitestgehend zum beispiel verbieten
auch das ist ja durchaus nicht
ungewöhnlich dass dann zb wenn ich jetzt
sage ich mal drei personen haushalt habe
mutter vater und zwei kinder und die
werden sicher erwachsen dass ich dann
auf eigenbedarf meine mieter aus der
wohnung raus werfen kann und da will die
linke sehr klar eingreifen an der stelle
und sage mal so die größten freunde von
großen vermietungs konzern sind jetzt
auch nicht unbedingt
kernpunkte der linken
bundesweiter mieten deckel und besonders
hohe mieten absenken
spekulation mit wohnraum verhindern
mietwohnungen sollen seltener zu
eigentum umgewandelt werden
bei der spd gab es jetzt eine größere
diskussion ob vermieter an den
heizkosten beteiligt werden sollen die
ihre mieter verursachen wie sie da jetzt
der konkrete plan aus tatsächlich geht
es dabei der frage darum dass
tatsächlich vermisst einen gewissen
anteil mit beteiligt werden sollte dabei
soll natürlich auch ein gewisser ein
stück weit auch klimapolitisch für
anreiz geschaffen werden zur sanierung
im prinzip war natürlich mit sanierung
dann dementsprechend aus energetischer
sanierung
inkonsequenz natürlich auch die die
heizungs preise einfach singen eine
bessere dämmung auch von gebäuden
damit wären natürlich zwei dinge
verbunden auf der einsatz natürlich die
soziale komponente die bei einer partei
wie der spd noch sehr wichtig ist auch
immer berücksichtigt werden sollte war
natürlich steigen energiepreise steigen
die benzinpreise sind alles dinge die
natürlich vor allen dingen
geringverdiener sehr schlag treffen auf
einem ausmaß wie man sich das teilweise
gar nicht vorstellen kann und da wird
quasi hier so ein bisschen regulativ
soll eingegriffen werden haben sie sonst
noch andere pläne um mehr bezahlbaren
wohnraum vor allem in den städten zu
schaffen
tatsächlich die frage
generalsanierung und auch leerstand
bekämpfen ist natürlich auch so ein
thema spielt in vielen großen städten
rolle wohnungen stehen leer werden
einfach nicht aktiv genutzt das sind auf
der einen seite natürlich die art und
weise wie man damit umgehen kann auf der
anderen seite wird aber natürlich auch
darüber gesprochen wie fern bauen das
problem lösen kann und
das sind sich die parteien aber gar
nicht unbedingt so uneinig frage wie es
immer nur wie und was und wo wird das
tatsächlich gebaut kernpunkte der spd
mieten soll nur im rahmen der
inflationsrate erhöht werden
100.000 sozialwohnungen pro jahr
mietpreis bremse entfristen
kommunale bauflächen nicht verkaufen bei
den grünen soll es ja so neubau oder
umbau von bestand immer mit
energetischen sanierungen einhergehen
wie sieht das ganz konkret in dem
wahlprogramm aus der die energetische
sanierung soll dann beispielsweise und
verbunden werden mit besserer dämmung
das soll dann verseuchtes verbunden sein
mit
solaranlagen die besser eingebunden
werden gefördert werden sollen es ist
auch hier das thema bauen es hat einfach
ein kirschen der thema mit klima und
dabei werden recht klare vorgaben
gemacht wie diese energetische sanierung
dann tatsächlich aussehen soll und in
welchem ausmaß welche förderprogramme
von welchem volumen man sie tatsächlich
auch dann umsetzen möchte ich da in der
praxis
wenn die grünen mit in die regierung
kommen ist dann das einfamilienhaus auf
dem lande passe ich glaube nicht dass
das der fall ist wäre für manche
parteien vorteilhaft gewesen wenn man
das zum narrativ hätte machen können von
dieser bundestagswahl weiß man wie das
mantra der verbots partei der grünen
sehr gut genährt hätte es macht er auch
die 1 andere aussage gegeben haben
tatsächlich nicht aber natürlich spielt
schon eine rolle ich darf mir natürlich
auch nicht vergessen wieviel baut man zu
und gerade die frage
gehe ich jetzt hin und lasse jetzt quasi
zu das nochmal 20
einfamilienhäuser gebaut oder baue ich
quasi zu verdienen die höhe und schaffen
mehr wohnraum das vielleicht auch mal
ein bisschen kleiner ist
dafür jetzt aber einen im programm hat
man sich da sehr bedeckt das wird das
würde man auch nicht riskieren dieses
thema überhaupt an zu schneien weil man
eine sehr starke lobby natürlich ging es
sich hätte in der frage
kernpunkte der grünen recht auf wohnen
ins grundgesetz
mittel für sozialen wohnungsbau erhöhen
mietpreis bremse entfristen
mietwohnungen sollen seltener in
eigentum umgewandelt werden ist da die
fdp ähnlich gepolt auch hält die sich da
auch mehr zurück oder geht jedoch eher
nachfordern sagte wir müssen jetzt bauen
bauen bauen genau so ist das also
tatsächlich bei der fdp ist das kann
alles andere prinzip auch hier gilt
wieder er also der glaube an diesen an
den markt bei dem halt angebot und
nachfrage im prinzip das dominierende
thema sind und auch klar denn auch da
spielen natürlich fragen energetische
sanierung spielt eine rolle und auch da
werden ideen durchaus gemacht aber
tatsächlich das fdp programm sagt
eigentlich nichts anderes als es muss
mehr gebaut werden gebaut wenn gebaut
werden alle wenn wir bauen haben wir im
prinzip mehr freiraum wo menschen halt
auch wohnen können und auf der basis
kann man natürlich ganz anders dann auch
mit mietpreisen umgehen weil wenn ich
jetzt die möglichkeit haben zwischen 100
wohnungen wohnen könnte oder 10 kann ich
natürlich als vermieter ganz anders mit
dem preis arbeiten und da hat die fdp
natürlich er das konzept des freien
marktes schon freier markt schön und gut
aber will die fdp da auch irgendwie ein
besonderes förderprogramm aufsetzen oder
bleibt das dann eher im ungefähren im
beiprogramm nee also förderprogramme an
sich sind jetzt nicht unbedingt
kernkompetenz der fdp sondern es geht
halt wirklich darum innovative ideen
sollen sich halt durchsetzen und das ist
halt im prinzip genau die agenda auch
verfolgt wird ist klar
kernpunkte der fdp freibetrag beim
grunderwerbsteuer von bis zu 500.000
euro einführen
kostspielige baunormen vermeiden
mietpreis bremse abschaffen
bundeseinheitlichen digitalen bauantrag
einführen wohnungsmangel in der stadt
auf der einen seite auf der anderen
seite besteht deutschland ja nicht nur
aus städten und großstädten sondern es
gibt eben auch viel ländlichen raum in
dem es aber auch viel leerstand gibt hat
da vielleicht die union in passenden
planen um den ausgleich zu schaffen
das ist schwierig weil die union
natürlich auch immer vorm hintergedanken
arbeiten muss dass sie natürlich auf den
im ländlichen raum durchaus höhere
wahlergebnisse erzielt so das heißt also
gerade auch die kombination zwischen ich
schütze quasi heimat in
anführungszeichen also lokalen
erholungsräume
wälder felder natur das steht natürlich
im spannungsverhältnis zum wohnungsbau
das heißt tatsächlich was da er eine
rolle spielt ist wie kann man innovativ
diesen raum fördern alle alle parteien
gehen und sagen endlich nach augen hat
potenziale die man nutzen muss zentralen
abgehängt wenn es zum beispiel um
krankenhäuser geht wenn es um
arbeitsplätze geht aber die cdu und die
csu formulieren hat vorschläge wie der
ländliche raum in den nächsten zehn 20
jahren aussehen soll also lokale
laboratorien wo halt neue sachen
entwickelt der hatten technologie
infrastruktur das sind halt eben wieder
gesehen werden das heißt auf der einen
seite will man den ländlichen raum
attraktiv aufwerten dadurch dass arbeit
und natur gibt und auf der anderen seite
würde sich dann so ein bisschen das ist
wahrscheinlich die die die hoffnung der
wohnungsmarkt im städtischen raum besten
entspannen kernpunkte von cdu und csu
mehr investitionsanreize beim
mietwohnungsbau
planungs und genehmigungsverfahren
beschleunigen freibetrag bei der
grunderwerbsteuer einführen sozialen
wohnungsbau fördern wohngeld anpassen
wie geht die fdp an dieses thema
ländlichen raum stärken an es ist
tatsächlich sehr interessant weil die
afg so ein bisschen wieder auf dem trip
von 2017 noch aufgesprungen ist und vor
allen dingen in ihrem programm migration
als eine der themen überhaupt erkennt
die für den wohnraum problematisch sind
also sie legen ja im programm unter
anderem da dass es singles weise sind
die das eine rolle spielen warum die
wohnungsknappheit besteht dass migration
eine riesenrolle spielen so ein bisschen
wird abgelenkt davon was sie vielleicht
auch die kernprobleme tatsächlich sind
das ist aber auch natürlich das macht
die afg klassischerweise immer sehr viel
redet über ein thema und dann verbindet
sie es irgendwie in irgendeiner art und
weise mit dem thema migration das kann
auch manchmal sehr weit hergeholt sein
manchmal gibt es auch ähnliche
verbindungen aber das ist natürlich
jetzt
auch um abzulenken von den eigentlichen
problemen dass man vielleicht auch keine
antworten auf diese probleme hat also
ein ziel oder einen konkreten vorschlag
wie dem begegnet werden kann gibt es
nicht mehr genau und dann das das geht
aber ja genau wieder an den duktus der
afg stelle eine forderung auf weil im
endeffekt muss sich nicht darum scheren
ob die umgesetzt wird so und optimaler
weise kann man das natürlich aus sicht
der afd dann genau mit diesen negativen
verbinden menschen kommen deutschland
wohnung wird er weniger genauso mit
anderen bereichen arbeitsplätze z das
sind die klassischen negative die drei
wie immer bedient werden
kernpunkte der afd keine mietpreis
bremse kein mieten deckel bauverfahren
beschleunigen mehr wohngeld stadt
sozialem wohnungsbau
grunderwerbsteuer abschaffen wenn
immobilien selbst genutzt werden gibt es
denn eine partei die den absoluten
masterplan hat um den wohnungsmangel in
den städten zu bekämpfen das ist ein
sehr schwierige frage weil alle parteien
natürlich davon ausgehen dass sie den
einen masterplan haben die frage ist
halt wer hat generellen masterplan die
mit dem thema allgemein umgegangen wird
und kann man das irgendwie schaffen
sämtliche städtischen raum irgendwie
einander zu verbinden
was natürlich so der vorteil sage ich
mal im programm von cdu csu in dem fall
ist man hat sehr konkrete pläne wie man
den ländlichen raum attraktiver
gestalten möchte und dann halt auch im
prinzip eine entlastung auf dem
wohnungsmarkt natürlich zu erreichen
weil wenn es arbeitsplätze auf dem land
gibt dann gibt es ja auch keine anreize
eigentlich im städtischen bereich
unbedingt zu bleiben das heißt es wird
ein ganzheitliches konzept eigentlich
auch gefahren das wird aber auch
natürlich bei der cdu und die csu
erwartet weil da sitzt in ihrer wähler
in großen teilen aber ganz konkret
bleiben die meisten parteien
unspezifisch bei dem was und wie sie es
eigentlich umsetzen wollen konkret aber
weil der cdu csu findet man tatsächlich
noch sie wollen 1 5 millionen wohnungen
bauen so die frage ist aber auch da wie
werden die gebaut wer baut die werden
wie es der anteil von sozialwohnungen
beispielsweise darunter und das sind
halt alles sachen die bleiben offen
wahrscheinlich auch taktisch um da halt
um die anknüpfungspunkte natürlich
vorkommende koalitionsverhandlungen zu
haben und da muss man natürlich abwarten
wie das weitergeht